bienvenue dans cette émission avec comme
invité Jean-Michel Fauvergue bonjour
Patrice alors les les gens vous
connaissent évidemment vous avez été le
patron du Raid entre 2013 et 2017 c'est
à dire au moment le plus fort celui des
attentats de 2015 vous avez été député
ensuite pendant 5 ans et puis vous avez
écrit sur sur notamment vos missions de
policiers de mission aux raid et là vous
publiez un roman les hommes en noir
servir ou faillir c'est chez plomb je
dis un robot et c'est un vrai roman et
il faut faire attention parce qu'il y
aura on va en parler d'ailleurs il y a
beaucoup de de liens avec ce que vous
avez vécu ça commence on est
pratiquement au Bataclan mais faites
attention lisez bien le revend jusqu'au
bout vous vous allez voir il y a plein
de rebondissements c'est un robot compte
lâche pas c'est
c'est ça ça c'est ce que vous avez voulu
faire d'ailleurs je suppose aussi c'est
exactement ce que j'ai voulu faire c'est
à dire et tant mieux si c'est réussi
c'est très réussi bravo c'est exactement
ce que je voulais faire c'est à dire je
voulais partir de des faits réels que
j'ai connu et qui m'ont profondément
impacté qui ont un paquet toute la
France d'une manière générale les
raconter dès le départ alors oui dès le
départ on est dans un théâtre parisien
je cite pas le bataille pas
parce que j'estime que le le Bataclan
appartient à tout le monde et je voulais
pas me l'approprier donc d'une manière
générale mais on est dans un théâtre
parisien sur l'intervention et moi je
voulais
décrire ces interventions là
en y mettant un peu de technicité de
l'aspect opérationnel mais surtout
beaucoup de de sentiments de psychologie
de la psychologie de ce que ressentent
les uns et les autres ce chef d'unité
qui est le héros principal mais pas que
de la du roman qui s'appelle Gaby donc
ce qu'il ressent au moment de rentrer
dans le Bataclan ce que ressentent ces
hommes ce que ressentent les otages et
comment le temps défile différemment du
du au niveau du quand on se place dans
l'action évidemment on a fait le temps à
passer beaucoup plus vite que la réalité
et puis je voulais enchaîner sur ce
roman sur
vraiment des
en réalité c'est des ambitions croisées
à la fois d'un côté ce chef d'unité Gaby
de l'autre côté
un terroriste
et puis il y a aussi les terroristes qui
sont aussi habillés on doit on va parler
comme d'abord un petit peu de vous euh
d'abord physiquement je trouve que vous
êtes quelqu'un vous êtes quel âge vous
avez 69 66
mois réfléchir
non et physiquement voilà on a
l'impression que que vous entretenez
bien vous êtes vous avez au fond le
calme des gens qui ont connu le danger
peut-être c'est important le corps ah
oui oui bien sûr on va ça a été
important dans votre carrière on va
reprendre le vieil Edge de d'avoir un
corps sain dans un corps sain bien sûr
que c'était important le corps c'est
important parce que à partir du moment
où vous avez des problèmes et tout le
monde en a des problèmes mais pourtant à
partir de 11 et les problèmes importants
que vous entretenez pas quand vous vous
tenez pas mais ça joue sur le moral ça
joue sur dans le cadre des fonctions moi
que j'ai eu
mais dans le cadre de la vie de tous les
jours ça ça joue sur la décision
ça joue sur la possibilité d'être serein
face à une adversité particulière bien
sûr qu'il faut entretenir le corps et
l'esprit aussi et l'esprit aussi bien
sûr là vous êtes des dans le Roussillon
pas très loin de Perpignan c'est ça je
suis Catalans d'origine
Perpignan c'est une ville qui est
rassemblement national Louis
pas sûr que ça vous plaise énormément
mais en dehors de ça sans parler au fond
de positionnement politique qu'est-ce
qu'on connaissez au fond les les les
gens qui habitent là-bas qu'est-ce qui
vous disent qu'est-ce qui nous disent
quand il veut te rassemblement national
ben écoutez ils ont seulement voté pour
pour Monsieur Aliou pendant les
municipales mais ils ont aussi renvoyé
quatre députés
du rassemblement national l'Assemblée
nationale mais si le s'il le font ça
c'est que derrière tout ça c'est pas par
Paris de logis extrémiste si font ça les
Français c'est que derrière tout ça
peut-être des questions il faut les
écouter qu'il faut les entendre alors
moi je suis pas de je suis pas issu de
ce camp là et par et par
oui oui par formation
peut-être tout à fait j'aime pas le
j'aime pas les extrêmes mais que ce soit
politique que ce soit dans la vie je
pense que les choses ne sont pas
réglables avec un claquement de doigts
et en et en
se repliant en se repliant envers des
idées qui qui excluent une partie de la
population
en plus les extrêmes ont une tradition
en France l'extrême droite en
particulier à une tradition de de
collaborationnisme et de et voilà on
montre ses muscles mais d'une manière
générale les programmes sont pas
derrière quoi mais quand même pour en
revenir à ce qu'on à ce qu'on disait
derrière il y a des il y a des le
lecteur qui attendent des choses et
évident qui se réfugient là dedans parce
que ces choses ne viennent pas en
particulier en matière de sécurité les
matières de justice
de sécurité de justice et je suis pas
persuadé que le programme d'ailleurs du
rassemblement national présente quelques
cohérents dans ce domaine là mais au
moins il fait le constat de choses que
pendant longtemps on a on n'a pas voulu
on n'a pas voulu faire et qui ce qui
commence un peu à bouger d'ailleurs donc
c'est que c'est quelque chose de moi le
choix des électeurs je le respecte d'une
manière générale donc je le constate et
puis aussi on parle de la des élections
municipales à Perpignan mais là aussi il
fallait voir comment la ville était
gérée auparavant et c'était quand même
ça n'était pas une grosse réussite vous
avez une enfant heureuse oui tout à fait
moi j'ai une enfance heureuse avec des
des parents
mon papa est né au Maroc c'était un
piment
maman était catalane de pure souche avec
le sale caractère des femmes catalan
oui
elles sont sympathiques aussi elles sont
présentes elles sont enrichissantes et
sympathiques
oui j'ai une enfant heureuse que j'ai
pas passé en pays catalan j'ai passé mon
enfance dans les Alpes-Maritimes pendant
11 11 12 ans et après nous sommes montés
avec mes parents sur Paris la plupart de
mes études sur Paris et la vocation de
policiers elle vient vite alors c'est
très particulier parce que moi tout
petit je voulais être policier je
voulais pas seulement être policier je
voulais être commissaire de police
pour pour faire des pour faire des
enquêtes des enquêtes judiciaires et
dirigées moi j'avais un je voulais aussi
diriger mais des policiers je pense que
je pense que honnêtement je l'ai eu mais
je l'ai eu mais au sens
avec le recul sur ma carrière je pense
que je l'ai eu au sens humain du terme
c'est à dire que je voulais diriger pour
emmener les gens vers les épopées vers
les aventures vers vers les les enquêtes
criminelles emmener toute une équipe
travailler en équipe
ça ça me plaisait beaucoup vous savez
tout jeune moi j'ai lu beaucoup beaucoup
de bouquins de sur la sur la guerre
d'Algérie sur l'Indochine
beaucoup de bouquins de chambersaire et
d'autres et cette cette aura des chefs
que que ce qui m'a massidéré en
particulier
Elie de noix de Saint Marc qui lui-même
a écrit des bouquins là-dessus qui
s'étaient un vrai chef humaniste qui
avait connu les affres oui mais qui
avait connu les offres de la de la
déportation il était résistant à 17 ans
il a il est il a pendant le putsch
d'Alger il a rejoint les quatre généraux
poutchistes mais il n'a pas
voilà il a refusé de donner des armes à
la population il est resté tout le monde
toujours admiré quoi quel que soit les
options
oui c'est vrai que c'est des figures qui
qui marque quoi ça donc voilà moi
j'étais versé de ça et j'ai voulu faire
flic et dans ma famille il y en avait
aucun de policiers j'ai voulu faire flic
comme ça de tout petit peut-être parce
que aussi
j'adorais et j'adore toujours les les
westerns et que moi la figure
emblématique dans un Acer et quand le
chérif était un pourri j'étais
complètement anéanti
c'est pas cher
donc vous avez fait des des écoles dans
l'école de de
commissaire de commissaire de police
de saint-cyromodo j'ai vu que la
dernière promo je crois que c'est une
femme qui majeure très bien c'est bien
bah oui mais bien évidemment moi j'ai
moi je me
dans mon dans ma promo il y avait des
femmes aussi je
candidatais pas pour être major et
c'était je me suis retrouvé largement en
milieu de classement mais l'essentiel
c'était d'y être de pas de participer
mais d'y être d'être commissaire de
police et ce que j'avais par contre
j'étais majeur en self-défense ah oui
alors on a aussi on a le titre quand je
dis parce que j'ai senti j'ai senti que
du costaud quoi et c'est bien là ça vous
défonce parce que ça ça prend le calme
aussi
donc donc voilà vous sortez de de cette
école de commission de police
commissaire vous commencez en
Seine-Saint-Denis vous occupez de la
lutte contre la drogue c'est ça oui
j'étais en service départemental de la
police judiciaire en Seine-Saint-Denis
qui dépend de la Préfecture de Police et
la partie judiciaire de la préfecture de
police et effectivement j'ai commandé le
groupe stupéfiant de la
Seine-Saint-Denis donc c'était un combat
permanent avec
énormément de énormément d'affaires à
l'époque et ça c'est pas calmé
aujourd'hui on verra tout à l'heure
le terrorisme et d'ailleurs le vous avez
d'abord un poste en Guyane et puis après
vous occupez de la sécurité de dans les
ambassadeurs au Mali au Gabon au Mali
c'est là que vous commencez à vous
intéresser aux théories ou en fait c'est
postes d'attacher de sécurité intérieure
c'est comme ça qu'on les appelle sont
des postes sont occupe pas uniquement la
sécurité de l'ambassade mais on s'occupe
aussi de la collaboration de la
coopération avec la avec la police
malienne avec la gendarmerie malienne à
l'époque on avait une coopération avec
le Gabon etc de la même manière et
effectivement moi quand j'étais au Mali
il y avait un groupe qui était l'ancêtre
de el-kaida au Maghreb qui s'appelait le
geste le groupe de salafistes de
prédilection et de combat
dont je parle
dans le vivre dans le livre et ce groupe
là c'est un des premiers groupes
terroriste c'est une dissidence du GIA
et qui était installé aussi aussi au
Mali et sur lequel on travaillait en
termes de renseignements
après vous êtes à la direction de police
aux frontières et puis le raid
c'est quoi le raid
ça signifie recherche assistance
intervention dissuasion c'est l'équipe
nationale de d'intervention de la police
nationale sachant que de l'autre côté on
a la gendarmerie nationale avec le
fameux GIGN la France a la l'avantage
d'avoir deux gros groupes nationaux qui
sont mondialement connus leur aide et LG
IGN qui se ressemblent un peu dans leur
moi j'estime et je trouve qu'il se
ressemblent ils se ressemblent
énormément alors après il y a des
petites des petites différences à la
marche mais ça se ressemblent énormément
vous avez un autre groupe qui est un
groupe tout à fait local de parisien
c'est la BRI à Paris mais c'est pas un
groupe national et il est pas réservé
uniquement à l'intervention puisqu'il
faut aussi des filatures et des
surveillance donc le raid c'est le raid
c'est ça c'est le raid va où toutes les
autres unités de police ne vont plus
parce que
la situation est dégradée et alors pour
répondre à votre question effectivement
le raid était pour la plupart des
policiers c'est c'est
l'unité l'unité à intégrer à suivre
c'est aussi une unité même si on
l'intègre pas très respecté des
policiers et
qui qui la vitrine de la police et qui
apporte une image de la police qui que
tout policier
auquel tout policiers se raccroche c'est
important à ça d'avoir une vitrine de ce
type là justement parce que je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup de candidats et peu
d'élus alors vous vous avez des
nouvelles voilà mais mais il y a
beaucoup de politiques doivent postuler
aux raid enfin qui essaye entre elles se
font quand ils sont par retenus
qu'est-ce qui deviennent ils sont pas
frustrés ils sont alors quand ils sont
pas il faut savoir que la police
nationale offre une
échantillon
[Musique]
un prisme de métier différent
extraordinaire donc
ceux qui rêvent de faire de
l'intervention il y arrive c'est bien si
il arrive pas il peut faire autre chose
hyper passionnant vous avez les enquêtes
judiciaires qui sont passionnantes vous
avez leur enseignement qui est
passionnant renseignement sur les
terroristes le renseignement sur les les
pays extérieurs qui viennent faire de
l'espionnage donc du contre-espionnage
vous avez la formation vous avez la
coopération à l'étranger vous avez des
tas de choses la police aux frontière
plein plein plein de trucs dans dans la
police nationale qui fait que vous ne
pouvez pas un certain moment même si
vous n'allez pas à l'endroit où vous
voulez vous ne pouvez pas être frustré
si vous avez cette ouverture d'esprit
qui vous permet d'aller dans tel ou
telle possibilité la police nationale
vous offre un éventail 15 possibilité de
carrière différentes d'accord mais
parfois non je me disais mais parce que
on voit pas justement des types que vous
écartez parce qu'ils ont un peu cet
esprit là oui alors ça c'est la oui
effectivement le recrutement du raid le
recrutement du raid il est aligné sur
plusieurs choses d'abord il y a des gros
des gros test psychologiques
individuels et collectif mais en fait on
aligne nos notre recrutement sur quelque
chose d'important c'est la possibilité
de travailler en équipe celui qui n'a
pas cette possibilité là celui qui est
trop individualiste pardon
il y arrivera pas et puis la deuxième
chose c'est que on a on a besoin de gens
qui sont
posées calme et et donc pas ceux qui
veulent
seul voilà donc on a besoin de ces gens
là et ces gens-là
voilà et dans leur vie privée ils
doivent être
particulièrement posé calme etc on est
on élimine les parce que on a besoin de
cet esprit là au rêve dans le roman on
va venir mais
tous ceux qui travaillent au raid ils
ont pas une vie de couple ou de famille
très épanouie ils ont des problèmes
c'est c'est quelque chose que vous avez
constaté non non du tout alors le
romanesque le roman c'est oui j'ai
exagéré vous savez il y a des
personnages sur lesquels je quand on
fait un roman on pousse le trait un peu
et quelquefois les les caractères sont
mélangés font partie de plusieurs
personnages réels etc donc oui eux ils
ont une vie un peu dissoluée dissolu on
échec
c'est pas le cas c'est pas le cas de
c'est pas un cas général d'une énergie
il faut être il faut être bien dans sa
vie privée quelle qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs mais parce que c'est le seul
moyen quand vous les horreurs que nous
avons vécues de s'apaiser et de pouvoir
se reconstituer en fait c'est un moyen
de lâcher son stress de lâcher ses peurs
que d'avoir une vie réglée à l'extérieur
avec la famille avec les amis avec une
vraie vie sociale quoi il y a des femmes
Rennes oui mais pas beaucoup oui il y a
pas beaucoup de femmes pourquoi parce
que
parce que la problématique c'est que on
a les gens les opérateurs du RAID ont
sur eux un peu plus de 40 kg de matériel
c'est trop
lourdes
Gaby c'est trop lourd d'ailleurs lui il
prend pas tout le matériel exactement
exactement il y a une problématique très
réelle entre le fait de ce s'habiller
comme des Robocop et se protéger de tout
et d'essayer de d'être plus violent et
souplesse il y a une vraie problématique
qui est abordée d'ailleurs dans le dans
rapidement
et pour en revenir aux femmes moi
j'avais au raide de deux femmes qui
étaient sniper qui était tireur d'élite
oui parce que alors il y a les les
policiers qui interviennent il y a les
tireurs d'élite on parle aussi dans le
livre c'est deux fonctions différentes
et puis il y a ceux qui parlent il y a
des négociateurs oui dans dans les
unités d'intervention vous avez
plusieurs
expertises vous avez la colonne d'assaut
et mais au-delà de la colonne d'assaut
vous avez les snipers vous avez les les
négociateurs vous avez les techniciens
qui travaillent avec des drones qui
travaillent avec des robots des on a
besoin pour l'intervention vous avez une
équipe de de toubib qui est dirigée un
chef médecin vous avez
[Musique]
vous dites où est-ce qu'on se dit le
danger là il s'est pas enfin il s'est
pas forcément déclaré encore mais voilà
il faut se préparer au pire
moi quand je prends le commandement
durée d'abord je le prends à un certain
âge après après toute une expérience
dans la police et 56 ans
tout à fait je suis plus âgé que que la
moyenne des des collègues qui ont pris
qui ont pris leur aide je je prends le
raid d'ailleurs avec avec un grade que
normalement on prend sur le on prend
raide qui était contre leur général
l'équivalent de général j'étais déjà
j'avais déjà mon grade et je et je viens
au raid avec toute cette expérience que
j'avais derrière moi là-dessus et je
viendrai aussi avec ce que ce que
j'entends ce que je sais de la lutte
antiterroriste et je viens en raide sans
la sangle sans illusion dans le domaine
de la lutte contre le terrorisme je sais
qu'on est dans une période très chaude
il y a eu la ferme Mera 14 mois
auparavant et
quand je et quand je prends le raid
assez rapidement on est touché par des
événements qui sont sur internationaux
je pense en particulier à la prise
d'otage du wisegate anaérobie soit
nationaux je pense à la fin de l'année
2014 de l'affaire de mouche ou le il y a
une tuerie dans un musée
en Belgique en Belgique et que
l'individu est arrêté est arrêté à
Marseille donc on sait qu'on est dans
une période
où il va se passer quelque chose on sait
pas quand on sait que ça va se faire
et donc
on tire les enseignements de l'affaire
Mohamed Merah et on transforme l'unité
qui commence à être transformée par mon
prédécesseur et donc je j'appuie ce
rythme là pour qu'on soit opérationnel
sur les nouveaux ce qu'on les
radicaliser les islamistes qui nous font
des prises d'otages de ce type là de
type Mohamed Merah et en s'entraîne là
dessus
je parlais de cette année 2015 on entend
souvent les acteurs qui disent je suis
pas sorti un dev de 9 films d'une pièce
mais c'est de la fiction vous avez été
confronté une réalité absolument
terrible est-ce qu'on est forcément pas
le même homme à vous et après
non on n'est pas le même homme avant et
après en fait
il y a une continuité bien évidemment on
a son caractère on a sa manière de faire
etc mais on est mentalement
[Musique]
fortement impacté par ce que l'on a vu
parce que parce que l'on a ressenti
quand vous rentrez au Bataclan je pense
que peu de gens qui ont assisté à un tel
carnage donc parce que vous avez
ressenti par le les actions que vous
avez faites par les actions que vous
avez pas faites que vous auriez voulu
faire pour sauver préserver beaucoup
plus de vie mais ça
voilà
on n'est pas maître de toutes ces
données là et oui on est fortement
impacté c'est véritablement ça aussi que
j'ai voulu j'ai voulu mettre dans ce
livre
et je suis évidemment pas du tout
appliqué mais je me souviens de le
lendemain matin le samedi matin
[Musique]
c'est alors Gaby dans le roman et le
patron de l'unité d'intervention le
renne n'est pas cité là aussi je voulais
je voulais que que tout le monde s'y
retrouve et pas juste oui vous voulez
pas vous approprier pour des faits même
si il y a des liens forcément oui bien
évidemment et
oui c'est l'enfer ça c'est ça c'est les
paroles qui ont été réellement
prononcées le jour de l'intervention
c'est l'enfer parce que c'est un
massacre absolu les les cadavres sont
importants vous vous quand vous rentrez
dans dans un dans un théâtre comme ça
vous avez le bruit des téléphones qui
vibre vous avez le 7 7 odeur de acre de
sang mélangé à la poudre vous avez un
tas de un tas de choses qui vous qui
vous percute immédiatement et qui vous
percute et quelquefois qui vous fige
donc vous il faut rapidement que que
vous arriviez à vous surtout quand vous
êtes le que vous arriviez à reprendre
vos esprits pour ensuite mener vos
hommes au combat et à la délivrance de
des autres otages qui ont qui n'ont pas
été massacrés et c'est là peut-être que
la
peut-être que le roman dit peut-être
plus de choses que nous dit un récit
c'est-à-dire que oui il y a des hommes
parfaitement entraînés qui savent
exactement quelle est leur mission même
si il faut décider au moment précis de
qui va faire quoi mais il y a aussi ce
qui apparaît dans le roman c'est à dire
la douleur
la peur vous en parlez pas il y a pas de
peur
ça s'évoque pas quoi c'est c'est dans le
non honnêtement il y a pas de peur
parce qu'il dans la réalité des choses
il n'y a pas de peur sur la sur l'action
pendant l'action
il peut y avoir des peurs rétrospectives
la peur d'avant non parce que cette
unité là fait que elle est faite pour
intervenir sur des choses les plus
alors il peut y avoir de la préhension
mais pas la pas de peur physique qui
empêche l'intervention oui parce que
vous savez quand vous avez un gros
stress ou une grosse peur il y a trois
il y a trois attitudes c'est soit le
combat soit le retrait soit
vous êtes figé par par les choses alors
être figé c'est la plus mauvaise des
choses le retrait peut s'expliquer dans
certains cas on fait retraite
on rassemble ces forces et on repart
ensuite au combat mais là il est hors de
question pour une unité d'intervention
de faire retrait et donc il y a que le
combat qui est il y a que le combat qui
qui la seule option qu'on a c'est que et
kagabi dans ce dans ce roman c'est le
c'est le combat donc non on parle pas de
la peur mais cette peur cette peur est
présente Gaby en parle aussi et c'est et
là pour le coup c'est la mienne c'est à
dire la peur de perdre des hommes
combats
il y a le sentiment c'est ça que vous
êtes aussi responsable de la vie de ceux
qui vous entoure quand vous êtes chef de
pendant ces périodes-là vous avez
plusieurs vous avez sur le dos une
responsabilité énorme plusieurs
responsabilités non la première des
responsabilités c'est de réussir la
mission parce que
personne d'autre n'y va et tout le monde
compte sur vous et en particulier toute
la structure de l'État compte sur vous
dans ces dans ces solutions la
France avait les yeux fixés là-dessus
que ce soit sur Vincennes ou sur sur
l'hyper cacher à Vincennes la France a
les yeux fixés là-dessus et et les
Français se disent
être encore plus réel parce que c'est
dans l'après-midi les chaînes de télé
étaient là enfin c'était
filmé
et donc les Français se disent bon il
faut que cette unité d'intervention
nous sommes etc et ça devient un emblème
l'unité d'intervention donc vous avez
quand vous êtes chef vous avez ça sur le
dos vous avez aussi sur le dos et bien
le fait de réussir la mission de sauver
les otages c'est important le plus de
tâches possible au Bataclan sauver tous
les à Vincennes à l'hyper cacher de
Vincennes on a sauvé tous les otages
tous
je n'oublie pas qu'il y avait quatre
tâches tués avant qu'on arrive c'était
avant on a sauvé tous les otages et ça
c'est c'est c'est extraordinaire mais
vous avez cette cette peur aussi de
perdre sur le dos de de perdre aussi vos
gars celui que vous connaissez celui
avec qui vous prenez le café vous
connaissez son épouse et tout vous avez
peur de le perdre au combat et moi c'est
une peur qui m'a qui m'a tiraillée
jusqu'à la fin du de vous avez des
pertes non j'ai eu des blessés j'ai eu
des blessés
qui sont bien remis de leur blessure je
n'ai jamais eu de de perte au combat
les autorités politiques les autorités
policières qui sont mais vous racontez
dans le roman et est-ce que ça c'est
peut-être un peu de réalité une
difficulté au départ de communication
appelée personne de répondre etc
c'est arrivé aussi dans ce Camille alors
c'est romancé aussi bien évidemment mais
ça part de fait réel c'est à dire que à
partir d'un certain moment
sur sur des interventions normalement
intervention de ce type le raid doit
être appelé immédiatement
ce ne fut pas le cas ni dans la réalité
ni dans le roman et mais il y a la il y
a l'initiative du chef qui est qui est
là quand vous êtes chef du d'unité
intervention de la police nationale et
qui se passe
ce qui a été fait dans la réalité des
choses pourquoi on n'a pas été appelé
parce que c'est une panique généralisée
y compris sur les ondes sur la radio
police nationale qui était hyper saturé
il y avait des attentats partout
exactement
je suis allé au fur et à mesure j'ai
j'ai informé mon mon directeur général
vous savez le chef du chef du Raid il a
au-dessus de lui un directeur général et
après c'est le Ministre donc informé mon
directeur général je vais atteint
l'endroit je me positionne à tel endroit
j'ai mis ça j'ai mis tel effectifs en
alerte là j'y vais etc et à chaque fois
mon directeur général m'a dit ok allez-y
allez-y et après vous avez vous êtes en
vous êtes en lien direct avec la devise
le ministre comme dans le
vous parlez alors le roman il y a des
des flashbacks si je peux dire
il y a notamment un flashback sur un
attentat qui ressemble à celui de
l'hypercachère et je reviens parce que
là justement c'est là qu'on va faire
connaissance d'un autre personnage
essentiel du roman et quand je te disais
tout à l'heure les hommes en noir c'est
les hommes du rêve la liste aussi mais
c'est aussi des terroristes et ça c'est
et ce roman aussi c'est le face à face
d'une certaine façon entre Gaby le
patron du Raid et
Wahid enfin qui est théorie c'est un
jeune qui vient d'Algérie qui est très
brillant d'ailleurs
c'est important
il y a des gens très brillants comme ça
qui sont
des études bien évidemment ce roman est
aussi intrusif
aujourd'hui parce que vous allez être
voilà vous avez pas arrêté vous avez
qu'est-ce qui se passe par la suite
de tout type alors on en a qui sont pas
très très bonne plafond si j'ose
m'exprimer ainsi et mais vous avez aussi
des intelligences extrêmes et des gens
qui sont ambitieux et qui veulent faire
excusez-moi cette expression là qui
veulent faire une carrière et c'est le
cas de Wahid qui veulent faire une
carrière dans le dans dans ce qui voilà
qui veulent aller au sommet de de cette
barbarie là parce que que vous soyez
informé sur le fonctionnement de la
police du raid etc bon ça se vendait pas
étonné mais sur le sur le terrorisme
alors avec deux choses qui sont qui sont
très importantes ce que vous disait
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des ambitions il
y a des conflits
c'est assez souvent très violent dans la
façon de se régler entre ils n'ont pas
une une passion pour la vie pour la vie
des autres qui les étouffent si je peux
dire et puis le trafic de drogue
oui parce que la plupart de nos
terroristes sont des gens qui ont déjà
un des condamnations
de
pénal et la plupart du temps dans le
trafic des studios c'est en fait en
réalité c'est là où
les extrémistes recrutent le plus c'est
à dire dans ces vendeurs de stups qui a
un certain moment n'ont plus aucune
barrière et ce et se rit des barrières
morales et légales de notre société et
des valeurs de notre société mais qu'à
un certain moment ils ont besoin comme
tout être humain on a besoin de
structures mentales et se retrouvent
dans les dans des structures mentales
qui leur sont qu'on leur fait miroiter
que sont cette extrémiste
djihadiste c'est extrémisme
de religieux
qui leur va bien parce que ça leur donne
à la fois des règles morales mais le
règlement qui leur permet de tuer les
autres on va être clair dans ce domaine
là donc il reste dans leur domaine de
compétences mais en se mettant un vernis
de moralité un pseudo vernis de moralité
et c'est pour ça que ça fonctionne parce
qu'il suffit qu'il est derrière des gens
qui fassent miroiter tout ça et beaucoup
de gens savent le faire on est un peu
dans un esprit sectaire et les choses
fonctionnent de cette manière là c'est
ce que j'ai voulu décrire dans dans le
livre c'est ce que j'ai voulu décrire
j'ai voulu aussi d'écrire le les
tiraillements qui a entre eux entre les
divers groupes par exemple les les
Iroises c'est-à-dire Juan c'est les
frères c'est les Frères musulmans d'une
manière générale on va simplifier les
salafistes les Irois les wahistes etc
qui entre se font ce ce sont des guerres
farouches et sur notre territoire
national aussi tout ça
mais tout ça est une réalité des choses
alors
après on est dans un roman noir donc
cette réalité elle existe mais elle est
romancée donc c'est une réalité mais
quand on parle pas des quartiers
des quartiers trafic de drogue est
important et puis la tienne un peu
certains quartiers
ça a souvent des liens avec le vous avez
beaucoup de liens entre le entre le la
vente des stupes et les le caïda dans
les quartiers les caïdes et
effectivement une émergence de
salafiste ou de Frères musulmans dans
les quartiers alors elle se fait
différemment l'émergence salafiste elle
est pure violence
là je simplifie aussi mais bon on n'a
pas trop le temps de et
l'émergence des des Frères musulmans
elle est plus insidieuse elle se fait
par des
la reconstruction d'un espèce de de
d'avantage d'avantage sociaux dans des
dans des quartiers qui sont donnés a
besoin et aux autres et sur les
évidemment par ses frères musulmans là
qui prennent la main sur sur ce quartier
là c'est plus insidieux on le voit
d'ailleurs dans le livre parce qu'il y a
ces deux tendances là qui se qui vont se
frotter les unes aux autres
il y a aussi
on verra dans le roman le rôle d'une
femme qui est assez intéressante il y a
aussi évidemment le renseignement qui
joue un rôle et social on dit beaucoup
d'attentats ont été évités plus
d'attentats presque éviter que que
d'autres questions
de plus pour donner un chiffre dans
l'année 2016 donc quand j'étais au raid
on est intervenus parce que le raid
intervient aussi sur les interpellations
d'individus dangereux à l'intérieur des
lieux clos le matin que ce soit le grand
banditisme que ce soit un banditisme qui
est pas qui c'est pas de la criminalité
organisée mais dangereux le vendeur de
stups en particulier avec leur calacciov
ou que ce soit les les terroristes bien
dans l'année 2016 le raid est intervenu
plus de 400 fois là-dessus et à procéder
à l'interpellation de 180 terroristes
180 terroristes à la demande de la de la
DGSI ou de la ou des services
antiterroriste de la publicité
il y a aussi une réflexion pour se faire
puisque le roman se passe
beaucoup dans l'année 2015 en tout cas
sur les actions après il y a des
flashbacks et
puis il y a même ça va même un peu plus
loin et puis on va parler après de la
politique
mais mais c'est spécialiste de la parce
que vous êtes un des grands PC de la
sécurité justement il y a eu ces
attentats de 2015 avec des organisations
très fortes Belgique ça veut dire de
Siri enfin
aujourd'hui les attentats que l'on a à
faire on a l'impression que c'est des
gens isolés qui tout d'un coup
totalement irremplérable pour le coup
qui passe à l'acte comme ça est-ce que
après les gros attentats que qui ont un
sanglanté la France en 2015
il y a eu aussi un grand travail de fait
par un service de renseignement et nos
services antiterroriste et en
particulier dans leur dans leur
relationnel international dans les
relations internationales importantes
avec les pays de l'Europe mais avec
l'ensemble des pays y compris d'autres
pays qui sont qui sont touchés par le
par le terrorisme pays maghrébin en
particulier donc voilà c'est une grosse
grosse coopération qui fait que et puis
vous avez eu en même temps le travail de
nos armées pas que les nôtres mais
l'ensemble de la coalition qui a
travaillé sur le Levant et on doit dire
que
à cette époque là travailler à
l'extérieur et le travail de nos armées
a contribué au travail antiterroriste
pour pas qu'on les attentats à
l'intérieur tout ça a été lié donc les
choses avec la disparition de l'État
islamiste enfin la disparition avec la
réduction de l'État islamiste évidemment
on a plus à faire directement des des
attentats de réseau par contre pour le
coup malheureusement la France est pas
que la France en Europe est un des pays
qui produit lui-même sur son terreau
national des terroristes qui peuvent se
radicaliser rapidement passer à l'acte
seul et faire et faire des des tas de
victimes pour autant je rappelle Nice
par exemple
le prêt ou alors toucher des figures des
symboles le prêtre rappelez-vous du
prêtre rappelez-vous récemment de Samuel
Paty donc c'était ici voilà on a on a
oui c'est le département qui a été
touché donc on a cette
ce danger qui existe toujours du de du
terrorisme endogène il faut beaucoup
plus compliqué alors pour le coup à
prévenir c'est compliqué à combattre
parce que parce que comme ça sa
communique peu avec d'autres personnes
nos services de renseignement sont un
peu aveugles là-dessus mais un travail
de fond quand même qui se fait je je
tiens à le dire alors parlons un peu de
politique puisque c'est dans le roman
Gaby donc chef du Raid va se retrouver
en 2017 à soutenir un jeune candidat
on sait pas s'il va pouvoir arriver à
son ambition d'être président de la
République qui a 38 39 ans
et puis et puis qui était lui président
de la République et évidemment on se dit
bah Jean-Michel fauvergne qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait il a il a vous avez soutenu
du pêche
une personne au départ j'ai non non j'ai
soutenu personne au départ en tout cas
vous avez été contacté par l'entourage
d'Emmanuel Macron pour donner des
conseils sur la sécurité est-ce que vous
avez fait tout à fait
et puis et puis je pense que vous a
demandé de vous présenter au législatif
vous êtes présenté vous avez été élu
vous êtes deviné députés vous aussi oui
en fait en réalité j'ai alors après il
faut dire tout de suite que dans le
roman c'est là qu'on va voir que c'est
de là aussi qu'on va voir que c'est un
vrai impact là parce que je dis il y a
plein de rebondissements mais là aussi
on va voir que les trajectoires de votre
et la vôtre sont déjà très différents
sont différents mais effectivement je
voulais aussi mettre cet aspect
politique cet aspect politique non
seulement je l'ai vécu à titre personnel
mais c'est pas que ça je constate j'ai
constaté aussi que le politique est
toujours présent dans l'action dans
l'action de police ou dans d'autres
types d'actions dans l'action économique
sociale aujourd'hui on le voit la
politique est énormément présente et
quelquefois il a une présence
importante et décisive et il faut
qu'elle avoir cette présence là et
quelquefois
cette présence là elle est elle est
lourde elle est inexpérimentée et elle
empêche l'action il y a deux choses
différentes
c'est de la lourdeur quoi c'est c'est on
prend des décisions plus rien je sais
pas quoi c'est ça la frustration enfin
oui et ça qui est décrit et moi j'ai
décris ce que ce que j'ai vu et il faut
que les les gens le sachent c'est que
même si un homme politique quel qu'il
soit qui est au pouvoir qui est au
manège veut changer certainement de
choses et bien il se heurte à un certain
nombre de freins et ses freins je les ai
décrit rapidement dans ce dans ce roman
j'ai essayé de les romancer aussi de
faire en sorte que ce soit pas que ça
soit pas trop
rébarbatifs qui sont les le poids des
administrations le poids des syndical le
poids des structures années des espèces
de de les les autorités administratives
indépendantes
et vous avez le poids de je cite la CNIL
d'ailleurs je vous avais le poids de des
juges administratifs un peu
institutionnel en même temps c'est le
c'est la démocratie c'est la République
mais il faut il faut
je pense que c'est le sentiment que
beaucoup de gens sur par exemple sur le
travail de la police qu'il est parfois
un peu ou empêché
c'est ça qu'on parlait tout à l'heure de
durant son national mais s'il y a aussi
ce sentiment là
c'est parce que oui oui alors on a un
vrai
pas faire de politique ici aujourd'hui
mais
un vrai problème de de justice et de et
d'exécution d'exécution des décisions de
justice un vrai problème il y a une
amélioration s'améliore parce que il y a
du budget etc mais il faut qu'on il faut
que ils font renversement de table
rapide sur cette affaire là
parce que d'autres profitent de ce les
Français à un certain moment se disent
des faits divers etc les types qui
auraient dû être en prison qui sont plus
elles étaient avant évidemment les gens
alors même si parfois ça peut
s'expliquer etc mais pour les gens c'est
un truc un oui avec
ouais c'est impossible et puis avec un
rôle de Parlement qui est qui est
difficile l'assemblée c'est difficile
sans relation je décrit aussi
les jeux toratoires entre les uns entre
les autres vous avez regardé un peu qui
s'est passé c'est ces derniers temps
c'est pas un peu décembre c'est
complètement décevant on a heureusement
on a Sénat qui reprend la main
heureusement Adam en toute dignité plus
de parce que ce qu'on aperçu mais moi je
suis pas mais moi c'est pas pour rien
que je suis parti de la ça c'est
une c'est une des des choses qui me qui
déjà apparaissaient
c'est une des choses qui m'a dit que un
certain moment voilà j'étais pas parti
pour faire une carrière politique déjà
après 40 ans de police j'ai fait 5 ans
et et pendant et 5 ans de politique et
pendant les 50 politiques je j'estime
avoir fait le avoir fait le job porter
une grosse une grosse loi qui est la loi
sécurité globale
être en contact avec les les ministres
de l'intérieur avec
voilà être dans le coeur de chauffe de
ça m'a beaucoup plu j'ai beaucoup aimé
mais un certain moment je me suis dit si
tu fais 5 ans de plus qu'est-ce que tu
vas apporter le plus la machine que
sachant tous les freins qui est qu'il y
a et qui sont romancés et qui sont
décrits dans ce royaume
il y a l'idée de servir
d'ailleurs c'est le sous-titre de servir
au foyer alors le la devise du raid
c'est servir sans faille et le servir ou
faillir le mot c'est le roman ça le haut
c'est dans le roman la réponse il y a la
fragilité évidemment des personnages je
crois que vous avez été invité il y a
quelques mois ici dans les
Business Club avec François Bouziane et
devant des patrons et j'ai discuté ils
ont tous ces impressionné parce que des
questions qu'on se pose quand on est à
la tête du raid sur le management des
hommes sur le la prise de décision
c'est évidemment c'est les intéresse
vous êtes contacté comme ça par des
entreprises ou pas c'est mon nouveau job
en fait en réalité moi je suis
conférencier en particulier pour les
entreprises et je travaille sur sur
alors je travaille quand l'entreprise me
demande c'est très c'est très fin comme
comme échange je travaille sur le en
général sur le management sur l'esprit
d'équipe sur la décision sur la gestion
de crise etc je travaille aussi un peu
sur la sécurité et
donc je réponds à mais il y a de nombre
d'entreprises qui qui est intéressée par
cette expérience là alors il y a
beaucoup de choses qui se et puis c'est
une expérience que moi j'enrichis avec
ce que me disent les patrons
d'entreprise c'est c'est je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure que je voulais dès le
départ moi commander diriger etc et j'ai
toujours ce sens là de la de l'échange
de la comment comment amener une
structure à son maximum en s'appuyant
sur l'équipe et pour s'appuyer sur
l'équipe il faut avoir un management
moderne aujourd'hui y compris d'ailleurs
dans des unités comme comme le raid
les troupes à l'armée aujourd'hui vous
ne vous ne montez pas à l'assaut vous ne
faites pas monter vos gars à l'assaut au
coup de sifflet comme en 14 vous vous
d'ailleurs en 1917 ça c'était c'était
terminé aussi aujourd'hui vous devez
leur dire pourquoi vous le faites quelle
est le danger qui vous allez sauver
comment ça se fait et puis il y a
derrière l'esprit d'équipe le les gens
auraient comme ailleurs montent à la
source parce que ils veulent être avec
leurs copains et leurs collègues etc il
faut travailler sur ces esprits et
suivre leur chef ça c'est la ça vient
juste après est-ce que vous disiez
d'ailleurs c'était que le souci que vous
aviez des banques de votre équipe dans
les interventions
voilà pourquoi j'interviens en
entreprise et mais c'est une richesse
juste un mot parce que vous êtes un
spécialiste sécurité il va y avoir la
Coupe du monde de rugby il va y avoir
les JO c'est des
important en matière de sécurité on est
prêt où il y a aujourd'hui non non pas
encore mais c'est pas aujourd'hui
alors moi je
suis de ceux qui je suis je ne suis pas
de ceux qui chaque matin
enfin un bashing en bonne et du forme de
de ce qu'on fait en France je pense que
dans certains dans certains domaines on
n'est pas les meilleurs du monde dans
d'autres domaines on a une belle
capacité on est quand même un pays
particulièrement
important dans ce domaine là avec des
beaux des belles unités
au fur et à mesure qu'on va se
rapprocher on sera de plus en plus près
la la problématique qu'on a c'est que il
faut
on a un problème de de comment dire
d'arriver à faire en sorte que nos
moyens en particulier technologiques
ne soient pas freiné par une idéologie
de d'atteinte à la liberté qu'on nous
brandit à chaque à chaque instant en
particulier on sait que la
reconnaissance faciale et bien
globalement
ça fonctionne mais on en veut pas donc
il faut faire des il faut faire ce qu'on
appelle des caméras intelligentes etc et
travailler sur ce qu'on appelle du B2B
c'est-à-dire que celui qui va avoir son
billet pour rentrer à un dans un
événement et bien on peut on doit
pouvoir avec une caméra ou avec une un
recueil de d'emples voilà et ça on va
gagner du temps et on va travailler
là-dessus donc c'est un petit c'est un
petit écueil qu'on a mais sinon d'abord
le public le public qui va se rendre à
la coupe du monde de rugby c'est en
général un public qui qui respectueux de
au championnat
sur le sur les Jeux Olympiques une
manière générale aussi sauf que il y a
certaines épreuves qui vont se passer à
certains endroits il faut être beaucoup
plus vigilant merci infiniment merci à
vous bah je rappelle le titre du roman
donc les hommes en noir servir ou
faillir c'est chez plot c'est un roman
passionnant passionnant à la fois pour
ceux qui aiment le les romans noirs les
rebondissements passionnant aussi par
l'actualité qui qui nous raconte merci
merci beaucoup d'être venu merci
beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]